[Musique]
mardi à conflans sainte honorine les
élèves ont fait leur rentrée au collège
du bois d'aulne ils étaient accueillis
par niveau tout au long de la journée
dix-huit jours après l'assassinât de
samuel pâtit l'émotion était toujours
présente
une minute de silence a été observée en
son hommage en france le port du masque
est devenu obligatoire dès 6 ans des
parents d'élèves ont été prévenus de
cette nouvelle mesure jeudi 29 octobre
plusieurs commune yvelinoise ont décidé
d'aider les familles en fournissant des
masques aux enfants
les tests antigénique sont disponibles
en pharmacie depuis le 2 novembre
objectif désengorger les laboratoires
les pharmaciens ont répondu présents
pour cette nouvelle mission
plus rapide que le pcr le test est
disponible gratuitement et sans rendez
vous en économie la région ile de france
a présenté hier son plan de mobilisation
pour l'emploi
il vise à soutenir l es 790000
demandeurs d'emploi catégorie a de la
région elle proposera notamment dix
mille places de formation en e-learning
le télétravail à nouveau généralisée
pour ce deuxième confinement le
gouvernement recommande d'y avoir
recours massivement les entreprises
saint-quentinoise se sont très vite
adaptés et puis les élections
présidentielles américaines ont débuté
mardi 3 novembre l'événement oppose le
candidat républicain donald trump au
démocrate joe biden les américains
yvelinois ont pu voter par
correspondance
les résultats devraient être connus dans
les jours qui viennent
[Musique]